google has built a cloud platform that
supports many industries
and healthcare is one that is top of
mind
supporting from data scientists to
developers
to enable interoperability across
multiple data sources
and data types such as hl7 dicom
fire etc as well as leverage machine
learning
while also being able to be compliant
with regulations
the intention has been to accelerate the
growth of health care applications
that can provide interconnected
experiences harmonized
data insights and are easier to build
store and manage
and so in this episode of this cloud
solutions healthcare series
i will give you a quick intro
[Music]
now let's say you are a hospital with
multiple sites
as your patients move from one hospital
to another how do you bring
all their data together longitudinally
or maybe you're an insurance provider
and want to ingest
and analyze your patient information in
bulk
as well as enable patients to have a
safe and convenient access to their data
to make more informed health decisions
via their smartphone devices
you could also be an application vendor
who wants to make medical
and imaging records more seamless yet
safe to access between healthcare
providers
and their patients or you may be a
research organization that wants to
leverage clinical data to make models
for predicting breast cancer or diabetes
if so today you face many challenges
because data is highly siloed
and on top of that the stakes are high
if you don't align your data processes
to government regulations which could
incur very expensive fines
for not understanding new policies as
they evolve
this is where the healthcare api and
google cloud's
hipaa compliant tools help reduce that
friction since it offers a platform
for the medical industry to process data
into desired formats
build upon the required open data norms
aggregate and store data into available
schemas
that you can train ml models and have
systems that make data
portability easy it also has a growing
public data set program
that you can leverage such as chest
x-rays
or cancer imagery from a security
standpoint google follows a unique xero
trust model which has multiple layers of
security
from our data center all the way to your
browser and all products stated in the
terms of service are hipaa compliant
we know how sensitive your data is and
want to process it under your terms
it's also important to know that
customers and not google
own the data and they can take it with
them anytime
google has been committed to serving the
healthcare industry
and has been building products and
solutions for not only our own doctors
but also sister alphabet organizations
such as verily
calico google brain etc if you're
interested in learning more
in the next few episodes i will dive
deeper into specific solutions the cloud
healthcare platform offers
you can also leverage the resources i
have linked in this video's description
for now if you found this episode
helpful friends please click like or
subscribe to the channel for more
episodes
cheers
[Music]